all ideas come from somewhere else it's
an accumulation
and iteration of our thoughts
experiences
and references that we connect together
in novel and interesting ways
that's creativity in a nutshell in this
video we'll teach you a process
on how to utilize references to generate
ideas for your next design
project our guest instructor for today
is award-winning motion designer and
director
tom crait he's worked 20 years in the
business of design
and animation for clients like nike
jaguar
and microsoft enjoy this video with tom
crate
hello i'm tom crade and today i'm gonna
show you how you can use references to
come up with more
and better ideas for your projects stay
tuned
in a minute i'm going to share with you
a five-step process i use
whenever i'm coming up with ideas for a
new project
but before i do i just want to address a
common misconception
i hear around the idea of creativity and
that's namely this
idea that it's something that you either
have or you don't
and that truly creative people can
somehow pluck an idea out of thin air
well the truth is that nothing is
created in a vacuum
so even if you're not drawing
inspiration from images you've seen in a
book or
on the internet you're still referencing
things that you've seen or experienced
in the past
your mind is basically one giant mood
board and if it's anything like mine
it's a freaking mess in there so in
order to get clear
vivid ideas that we can share with a
client or members of our team
we want to get our references where we
can see them and organize them
in the words of picasso great artists
steal
let's go steal some stuff step one is
understand the brief
so the first thing we want to do is just
absorb all the information
we have available to us around the brief
we want to ask questions like
what's it for who's it for what kind of
emotions are involved
we really want to drill down to the
essence of what we're trying to
communicate
it can be helpful to break it down into
a few key words that really sum up the
essence of this communication
step two is stop thinking now this might
sound a little bit weird
but coming up with ideas is a bit like
trying to sleep
the harder you try the harder it gets so
the idea here is to
clear our mind so the space for new
inspiration to come in
step three is explore so now we've let
go of this idea of trying to think of
ideas
we just want to get in touch with the
emotions and the feelings involved in
what we're trying to communicate and let
that be our guide as we start collecting
imagery
step four is organize so once you've got
a good bunch of images that you're happy
with
it's time to arrange and organize these
images in terms of common visual themes
step five is solidify so now it's time
to put our logical mind to use again
and start to describe the common visual
elements and how they communicate the
core concepts from the brief so that's
the process in a nutshell
now let's take a look at how that might
work in practice okay so i'm just going
to take you through that process now
using the example of a project that i
worked on recently where i had to come
up with some concepts for a pitch
for a tv show opener the tv show was
a crime drama and the story was
basically
about interrogation and they're trying
to figure out what happened by
interviewing a bunch of people
so the kind of course concepts were this
idea
of subjective versus objective reality
and how like the truth can be distorted
from different people's perspectives
so once i kind of soaked in all that
information and created some keywords
i'm ready now to dive into the ocean of
inspiration that is the internet
let's do this okay first things first
i usually find myself a playlist
something that's going to help me
get into the right vibe and once i got
that
running it's time to fire up the old
browser and the first stop today
is pinterest pinterest is a great start
because
it's a really good way of organizing and
finding similar
images but don't just stop there it's
important to spread your neck
as far and as wide as you can for
example if i'm coming up with ideas for
a motion design project
i want to go way beyond anything motion
design related
at least for now so i want to be looking
at painting
sculpture installations architecture
photography
you name it the weirder the more
eclectic the better
and i'm just going to save everything
that resonates sometimes some really
cool ideas might pop
up and you can always make a quick note
of it in your sketchbook but then just
let it go and keep riding those waves of
inspiration
so here's the board where i've been
saving all my references for this
project
and i'm going to come in and i'm going
to start organizing them now there's a
few ways you can do this you can
either just save them to your hard drive
and put them in folders
there's also a handy feature in
pinterest that allows you to
create individual pages so you can split
things up into categories
so i'm going to do that here and just
start picking out images
that feel aligned with certain ideas so
there's some images here that i liked
with this puzzle effect so i'm just
going to
group those together i'm going to create
a page called puzzle and just throw them
in
so i'm just going to keep on sifting
through all these images that i found
and
sorting them into categories based on
common visual themes and as i do
some of these concepts should start to
become a little clearer to me so while
we're on this image
here what stood out to me was this kind
of nice graphic representation of
duality where
there's an image of a woman and then
there's a sort of a secondary layer of
color which
could be applied in many different ways
and this whole idea of a puzzle
like those kind of puzzle games where
you have to slide the tiles around and
it
somehow ties into this idea of the
interrogation and trying to figure out
what happened
sort of puzzling it out putting pieces
together and here's another one i liked
so the most obvious theme here is
distortion
there's also an idea of duality here i
think because
you kind of have this idea of beauty
with this kind of like a fashion model
and then
it's something kind of grotesque about
the way it's distorted and aside from
that it's just an interesting
image it's it's very graphic with the
black background the
high contrast and the the accent of the
very saturated makeup
i already have an inkling of how maybe
this could be applied to
footage to create an intro or a teaser
footage could be distorted faces
places things like that things that seem
normal and then could be changed to
create
another more interesting different kind
of composition
so now i've organized all my references
and now it's time to
bring my logical mind back online and
start to flesh out these
visual ideas into something a bit more
concrete so i like to use google slides
just because it's
super easy and simple you can just drag
and drop you don't have to think about
anything else
and this isn't for presentation at this
stage this is purely for me to get down
my ideas so
you can see i've got a collection of
some of these different ways of
representing that puzzle idea and i'm
just going to write down
how that can apply in the context of the
brief
and so the references i've chosen here
also represent some different
applications so i've got some
very graphic representations i've got
typography
i've got a more literal jigsaw puzzle
effect and then more abstract
combinations of typography and images
and i'm just gonna
write a few words about how these images
could tie together into some kind of
narrative or simply some interesting
visual animation devices and you can see
from just a few hours of searching
online i've come up with quite a few
different concepts so here's another
concept that came through with this idea
of a light bulb that kind of represents
that idea of interrogation if you think
about an interrogation room with like a
raw light bulb in it
playing with reflection and refraction
and how that can be used to distort
images and also light and dark so i've
just written a note that's
that sums up those concepts without
trying to sound
fancy or trying to sell the idea at this
stage this is really just for
me to share with members of my team and
throw some ideas around
so it's just a brief overview that
should communicate to me or somebody
else
how these images connect and communicate
the key concepts from the brief
some of them might overlap slightly but
the goal is really to cover as much
ground as possible
and i kind of see the whole process a
bit like panning for gold you're kind of
sifting filtering down all these ideas
to
get to some nuggets and then once you've
got those nuggets you can polish them up
into something beautiful hopefully
and just to give you an example of where
you could take this here's some pages
from
a treatment for a project i worked on
with tendril
so pitching an idea for a commercial for
a smart tv
we have a couple of pages of mood boards
there's a page here addressing one of
the core concepts
of the branding message it's trying to
convey a sense of kind of epicness
using landscapes and mysterious objects
suggestions are an idea of dna which
reflects an idea of a sort of
heritage and also an evolution and a
kind of futuristic vibe
and then here's a page describing one of
the features of the tv
like the audio quality of this product
and how we can represent
sound in different ways that are keeping
with the concept that we're creating
if you're going to write up these ideas
for a client in the form of a
pitch for example obviously you want
everything to be nicely presented
i think the most important thing is just
to remove everything that's unnecessary
so just pick the best images that really
speak to your idea
in terms of writing i really enjoy
writing but even if you're not confident
at all with your writing style i don't
think it's important i think what's
important is that you have an idea that
you're inspired by and passionate about
and if that's the case i think that will
come through regardless so really my
advice would be
just to keep everything short and simple
and clear
too much vocabulary too many fancy words
is going to keep it all
in the mind and it's actually going to
take away from the feelings of the idea
which is where the real inspiration
happens that's where people really buy
into an idea
there you go that's the process i use to
generate ideas using references
and if you're new to the idea of using
references like this
i highly recommend making a habit of
collecting and curating stuff that you
find
online or even out there in the real
world
if you see stuff that's interesting or
weird or inspiring
take a snapshot or a video and you'll be
creating a kind of repository a resource
of images and stuff that you can use
for future projects and not only that
you'll also be
developing a kind of design language
you'll be developing your own sense of
style and your own design eye
that's it i hope it was useful and i'm
going to hand you back
over to matthew at the future
thanks tom for sharing that wonderful
process it's very similar to what i use
when developing creative ideas for my
clients
if you want more of tom crate you can
check out his work and courses on his
website
at tomcrate.com and if you learned
something new or have a question about
what you saw today
let us know in the comments below tom
and i will be scanning through them
and answering the best we can if you
want to level up your own design and
business skills don't forget to check
out our free resources
and courses at thefuture.com
that's it for us i'm matthew encina and
we'll see you
in the future